Film Courage: When you’re writing a screenplay
do you start with an outline?
Rachel K. Ofori, Producer/Writer: I start
with somewhat of an outline.
I need to know where I am and then where I
am going or where I just came from.
Usually for me when I am starting to write
it’s not coming from a starting place, it’s
coming from a scene I’ve already had so
I write that scene out, the most vivid thing
about what I think about this idea, I write
that scene out any…it doesn’t have to
fit anywhere.
I don’t know where this is but I just see
these characters doing this at some point.
I start there because I kind of get my groove
going and I start to…yeah I really feel
this moment.
I see this moment.
I’m a very visual writer.
When ideas come to me they come to me almost
like a movie.
I’m able to write them down and then now
I go to an outline because I don’t even
know where this is.
I know I am here
but I don’t even
know where this
is in
the story